week's frightened you're a little girl
Canadians are soft Rocky was an American
come on come on pushing up pushing up
give me so hard nothing where's Kevin in
the world week Howard
am I a juicer that is probably one of
the top comments I get on YouTube no
this guy's got roids you know I've never
done a steroid in my life uh you know
what I'm actually not against steroids
I'm not against juicing and all that
stuff because you know it's got its
place in the industry cuz I'm gonna pick
you know I'm involved in the fitness
industry and all that and I know that
you know there's bodybuilders that can't
really step on stage without that
because that is their job that's in my
opinion that's the only people in this
world that really need to ever use them
but you know what i find it a compliment
whenever anyone says I am on Jews
because you know that just means I'm
doing something right well the whole
furious name kind of originated by
accident five and a half years ago I
needed to upload a video to YouTube and
I needed in the count I tried my first
name my last name and then all had like
all these random numbers after it then I
kind of just played around with a few
different names a couple of my buddies
used to be dr. furious had an email dr.
furious another one with another furious
and so I tried furious Pete I was taken
then I just furious Pete 123 on youtube
motul behold that kind of worked and
then I didn't know if that was going to
be an eating name or anything I just
need a username for youtube but for
whatever reason the whole furious aspect
when eating just just works I don't know
I go I really am furious whenever I eat
it's the only time really in my life
that I am furious daily basis of a
normal guy friendly guy but put food in
front of me you're scared you're scared
my family back in the day was definitely
not happy with all the eating I've been
doing uh you know because first of all I
think it's unhealthy I have a crazy
crazy history that follows along with it
and nowadays they see the entire
business aspect that goes along with it
they see all the travel opportunities
that go along with it they know my life
on a daily basis and they know that you
know I'm just doing this because it is
my job and this is what I do now and
they slowly began to accept it so
without going too much into detail and
or december 2002 i was hospitalized for
anorexia my heart rate went down to
about five beats a minute pretty much
hard stop you know that was just it was
just the lowest point in my life had a
lot of [ __ ] going on in my life parents
were sick about a year before that i was
told that might have cancer was the last
year of high school trying to get into
university so much stress built up in my
life that i just started using food as a
form of control to forget about all
those issues and i took it way too far
and be holding it up in the hospital
took about three and a half years to
fully overcome this eating disorder like
mentally because that is the big issue
it's not just you know the whole
thoughts inside your head that's the
biggest issue an eating disorder you
know somebody's telling you you're not
good enough you're too fat like all this
other stuff even if you're not develop
you know an image disorder so you see
something else obviously and took a long
time to overcome it lived a normal life
for about a year and then randomly buddy
of mine asks us to try and break some
record out of breakfast pub after a
night of drinking and I doubled the
record and this whole eating thing
started I mean of course I'm worried
about my long-term health like I don't
like I don't do eating stunts on a daily
basis you know I healthy on a regular
basis i like to eat healthy it's things
that satisfy me you know they empty
calories aren't necessarily satisfied
however this is my job to eat it is my
job to entertain and sometimes it like i
guess in the past I definitely had a
bigger thrill of trying to like
demolishing eating challenge now it's
like there are challenges that I do
which I'm happy that you know you like
you know for example when I did do a
Guinness World Record and I crush it you
know that's something that really does
make me happy and excited what would I
do a normal eating challenge it
definitely doesn't have to say thrill
factor but uh you know I don't do them
all the time I have to space them out
otherwise you know i would be worried
about my health and I'd be worried about
you know the way to look and everything
all this fitness stuff that I'm doing
would definitely you know be useless
right so yeah Oh give it to me believe
it be come on
come on glory
yeah i'm doing guinness world records
tonight yeah I'm gonna try and beat the
Guinness world record for fastest time
to finish a 12-inch pizza I I really
don't know if I've said my confident
with this one because you know a pizza
can be any number like it can be any way
you can be a big piece it could be a
thin pizza it's a thin pizza Finnick
recipe it's how I'm going to crush this
record if it's a thicker crust pizza who
knows it's going to be on the verge like
that the guy that holds the Guinness
World Record is undoubtedly the best
eater in the world Carol Kobayashi
Japanese do that it all those hot dogs
and everything he is you know
undoubtedly good buddy of mine but he is
he is the best of the best out there I
can probably beat him in a couple speed
things but not long distance wise but
yeah he has the Guinness World Record so
if i take it from him i'm gonna feel
pretty damn good about myself officially
I have a Guinness world record for
fastest fastest time to eat an onion a
raw onion just 43 seconds most for
O'Shea's eaten in one minute most jaffa
cakes eaten in one minute pretty sure
those are the official guinness world
records that i have there really aren't
that many food guinness world records
anymore but i am kind of like working
with them to try and make some more kind
of thing so my goal undoubtedly is to
own every single food get us world
record if possible i'd say the secret to
eating a lot of food really fast is I'm
not gonna tell you know you know it's it
all it's all about practice makes
perfect uh you know some people like I'm
definitely I've definitely gotten faster
over the years I've learned little
things you kind of like you can feel out
different things when you're eating you
kind of you just have to feel you have
to see what to do it's it's hard to
really explain what to do yeah you just
have to like see it to believe it or
like feel it to believe and feel it to
understand it so I started on YouTube
probably June 2007 I think I uploaded my
first video it was pretty much filmed
with a potato there was no voice worse
quality
I was eating some nuggets it was just an
eating challenge online to win some
supplements most nuggets eaten in two
minutes and I crushed that challenge and
basically the whole point of me
uploading videos for the first I say six
months was just me trying to win these
little challenges online and then I
started doing different restaurant
challenges post them online and the
whole point was to get noticed by
different eating leagues and stuff like
that to potentially be asked to come for
an eating contest one day and so about a
year after my first video maybe even
less I uploaded one of the fastest times
in the world t2 72-ounce steak along
with that I also did the most bananas
eaten in two minutes and after that I
was actually contacted by a guy in
California to come down for an eating
contest and went down with no
expectations and you know I blew away
the competition but that YouTube thing
you know I just pretty much used the
first three years probably of YouTube as
just wave to show my skills and show off
what I'm doing and and just just just
for fun kind of thing and then last two
years I've been taking it more seriously
you know hands-on approach with quality
and listening to the viewers and trying
to become consistent and all that you
know generally I'm pretty good with like
pleading the challenges that I set off
to complete I mean I hate mail that's
the issue with a lot of challenges that
you know a lot of a lot of food will
help Mayo out there that's one of my
kryptonite's unfortunately there's
definitely like you know foods that I
haven't mastered for example like trying
to eat hot dogs you know as fast as
possible it's definitely something that
I haven't done enough up to become
really good at it I've done maybe like
five or six contests with hot dogs and
something that I definitely want to
become better at but in general like you
know I've I do okay with with you know
for the most part with with all the
eating challenges that I try my dream
ultimately back in the day was to work
for NASA or something related to NASA
always had always had a fascination with
space and and all that so I don't know
you know what I'm just hoping that this
doesn't go to [ __ ] I'm hoping that this
will be my life I'm hoping that I can
truly make a good
this out of this a real business out of
this and ultimately that's my goal and
that's what I'm going to be pushing for
it sup guys check out my youtube channel
youtube.com slash furious Pete subscribe
and follow along also you can check
check me out on Facebook and Twitter
same thing furious Pete and see whatever
I've going on tune in all along get you
guys later